wir
am problem
dieses problem heißt hilf mir süchtig
nicht ohne
la
ich
die 19 jährige hat ein
großes geheimnis sie muss immer an ihrem
schnuller nuckeln
[Musik]
ja
mega großes geheimnis wenn sie da die
ganze mit der hand vor mund hält
sprachen lernen jetzt der schnuller ist
hingefallen ab wieder rein in der euro
damit dass es nicht
[Musik]
anna lisa li na ja keine ahnung welche
es sind bei ihren nacken und das gefühl
von innerer ruhe gekoppelt das würde
auch erklären warum sie in einer
stresssituation nachdem schnell
ergreifen werden noch nie so schnell
hier unsere therapeuten ingrid am start
völlig man kann sich auf die uhr schauen
heißt stunde wissen zu spät ich hätte in
unzeit
[Musik]
das war ganz blöd dass mir in beiden
dann abgefallen sind schnuller
hingefallen alles ja als interessiert
mich nicht sie hat schon würde würdest
du nicht an die arbeit machen so ja los
mach jetzt hier frei schilder der jemand
über weihnachten seine herzlichkeit
verloren
ganze dich mal ne ne ne ist klar das ist
ein praktikum muss oder und wenn mich
der box fragt wenn ich die letzte die
ein gutes wort wirklich einsetzen würde
[Musik]
was
ist schon genau was ist denn in der
folge hier falsch die eine ist total
süchtig nach ihrem schnuller und die
andere ist einfach ein eisblock ist und
nicht jetzt
das ministerium ist das reiche kamen so
in die hose
blödmann ist danach auch den boden ganze
ablecken barbara die art und weise wie
sie es zilina hier klar macht geht
allerdings gar nicht das muss man sich
unter kollegen nicht gefallen lassen so
der wunsch war aber ganz schnell wenn
ich hier die alina wäre würde ich mal
ganz schnell in den hörer greifen und
die polizei anrufen
mobbing ob in erster linie steht unter
druck
sie braucht jetzt dringend einen ruhigen
moment zu nuckeln und ich muss sagen
erst mal fett ein abreißen
ich brauche erstmal ruhigen moment zum
nuckeln
ich brauche dich jetzt redet sie gerade
mit ihrem sohn
[Musik]
jetzt ist victoria und spitznamen für
ihren schnuller so wunderbar da dran es
gibt einfach ein paar produkte
die sollte man einfach so lassen wie sie
sind
sonst schnuller
wofür braucht er so was gemeint ist 12
moderator hallo da wollt dann macht sie
das denn jetzt okay ihr pult ist
darunter
[Musik]
okay das verstehe ich jetzt wiederum
nicht
ich verstehe generell gar nichts hier
bisher aber dass sie sich jetzt das
schwingt auf der arbeit wenn sie ein
praktikum
[Musik]
ja ja ja
hier ist dann eigentlich immer mit denen
ich zufrieden bist du nicht kannst du
immer
schon wieder ist geführt alle 20 minuten
auf toilette einfach weil ich geh jetz
auch toilette und du bleibst hier
alleine und brauchst keinen scheiß denn
sie baut jetzt scheiß auf toilette seine
musik hilft mir hat sie irgendwas im
spiel
[Musik]
nein
in ihrem zimmer kann
opel sucht noch gehen
[Musik]
die wird jetzt passend zu ihrem outfit
auch noch ihren passenden schnuller aus
und hat da eine komplette schublade voll
mit denen
ich frag mich echt was den falsch läuft
und jetzt hat es den roten schneller da
ihr zimmer sieht auch ihnen die aus wie
sonnen insein gefängnis oder auf dem weg
in die arbeit
[Musik]
auf dem weg in die arbeit
in die hat in dieser folge jeder so
einen kleinen schaden sein den schnell
vergessen dass der chef
denn zeit ist abgelaufen und die
abgemachten dann hat man es dass die
kiste mit den preisen runter gefallen
ist und dass sondern einfach weg ich
dann bis es geht nicht dort gut einmal
klar musst du doch hier bisschen nuckeln
mit schnulli ich war ja da zum glück
kein team die einschleimen 1 war beim
chef wenig später selina hat sich
heimlich aus dem laden geschlossen und
sucht verzweifelt nach einem look
wer nennt der teil überhaupt nuckel nein
nein
[Musik]
ich will nicht mehr herstellen heutige
fühlen und freunde wenn keine hilfe die
ex gefangenen darunter wiederholt ein
kein terror in der lugner sein
[Musik]